[Music]  Parliament agreed on a target of a 37.5%  reduction in greenhouse gas emissions  from new cars before 2030 emissions from  vans should be cut by 31% five chemicals  have been added to the --use list of  harmful substances members voted on a  new law to better protect workers from  cancer-causing chemicals across a range  of industries Parliament adopted  copyright rules that mean the internet  platforms will be liable for the content  that users upload once EU governments  approve the text Member States will have  two years to implement the new rules  more than 80% of marine litter is  plastic members voted to ban single-use  plastics like straws cutlery cotton buds  and stirrers from 2021 members voted to  end the practice of adjusting clocks by  an hour in spring and autumn in 2021 EU  countries still have to accept the  proposal